[MUSIC PLAYING]
Home is more than just
the place you are in.
It's a feeling.
It was very dangerous if
I were to stay in Syria.
So many Syrians have had
to leave our country.
We have about 2.5 million
Syrian refugees in Turkey.
Small things that
were easy in Syria
suddenly become hard
in the foreign land.
I ask myself what I can
do for the refugees.
I know programming.
Gherbtna means "expatriation."
It helps Syrians navigate
a new life in Turkey,
for example, I want to rent a
car, I want to rent a house.
It helps connect
you with employers.
It tells you how to your
children into the schools.
Anything.
I love programming because
it allows me to do anything.
It seems there is no limit
to what we can accomplish.
Syria will always
be our country,
but it's possible to make this
new place feel like a home.
[MUSIC PLAYING]